most of you entrepreneurs are screwing
yourselves over and I'm going to share
today how to fix it so got a great
question for one of my super loyal
YouTube viewers love you guys tommy
oliver who wrote in the say my big
problem that I've always faces that
because of my self-confidence issues
I've never loved any of my ideas I've
always been like at best I've considered
tons of meetings and nothing has ever
really sparked my passion in a way
others seem to have when something comes
to myself I always perceive it as less
quality less real than something that
comes from outside of myself I know that
I want to create and be a storyteller
but I've never been able to get hype on
my own work because I don't have a
hundred percent faith in myself from my
abilities guess I'll just have to settle
for limited success this is one of the
most important questions I think I've
ever been asked on my channel and it's
holding a lot of entrepreneurs back see
what you have to understand is there's a
gap there's a huge gap between your
taste and your abilities so here's
what's happening you love storytelling
so as a result you're studying
storytelling right you're learning the
storytelling chances are it's something
that you love so much and you don't
really even have to put effort into it
you're you gravitate towards it
naturally you're reading about Martin
Luther King or Todd McFarlane or matt
groening and studying how they story
tell because it's something that excites
you so as a result your taste is up here
right you know what makes a really good
story and how to differentiate between
the good and the gray and of course the
really bad ones the problem is your
ability to tell the stories and create
something is down here your abilities
are nowhere close to your taste so
everything that you create sucks even
though you can create something way
better than the average person could
because your abilities do not match up
with your taste you're never going to be
happy you're always going to be
self-conscious and you're not going to
release anything important what you have
to understand is that to narrow that gap
to make your abilities match your taste
it comes to practice it comes to
repetition it comes from being
consistent you got to practice your
storytelling and spend just as much time
on that doing it yourself as you
did researching it to develop your taste
you can look at new youtubers an example
a lot of new youtubers they look at
other channels and say ah I really want
to be like that person look at how much
success or having look at how much
growth they're having and then they say
I could do that to I want to do that and
they turn on the cam when they put on
themselves and they make their first
video and it sucks and then they realize
because it's a huge gap right between
their buildings and the taste that
they're not going to release it and
they're not going to success until they
shove it down right if you have low
abilities and low taste you don't care
right if you thought what you did was
great because you don't have any good
taste so you're going to release it if
you have high Billy's in height eights
and you're going to put it out as well
but how do you get those abilities from
practicing so I've said a couple times
in my channel that it took me seven to
eight hundred videos before was it
embarrassed by my own content seven
eight hundred videos before I could
watch one of my own videos and not be
embarrassed by other people were loving
it people who live in comments before
subscribing liking it sharing it but I
couldn't watch my own video because I
was too embarrassed by it and then it
took me 14 hundred videos until I found
a video that i made that I love 1400
videos until a video came out that I
made that I was inspired and moved by
1400 videos man would you go out and
create 1400 stories and be willing to
put in that time and effort and
commitment it took me 14 hundred videos
for my abilities to come up and match my
taste that's what you need to do with
your business as well if you love story
talent you got to commit to it you got
to practice it and know that you're over
time going to bridge that gap and you're
not happy right now because your
abilities don't match up with a taste
but it's coming the only way like
anything else to get better at an
ability is to practice it and study it
and learn it and over and over and over
again be consistent with it the second
part of this that's really a mind game
is that a lot of us may have this deep
passion and want to be successful at
something but because it was that big
gap again that I talked about failure
for you is soul-crushing
right if Tommy feels like he loves
storytelling it's who he is it's the
only thing he's ever been passionate
about now failing that storytelling if
he fails at that he's got nothing and a
lot of us have that we feel like if we
fail at this one thing that we're
excited by then we're so afraid of
failure that's gonna be soul-crushing to
us and so we're not going to try and
it's better to go and do other things
and try and fail at those things because
you know I you know I it wasn't I wasn't
excited about that anyway so it's okay
if I fail and all the meantime not being
willing to bet on the big thing that you
want to go after what you have to
understand is that failure is normal
you're going to fail it's okay your
stuff will sock just like any other
skill that you're trying to learn you
trying to learn how to ride a bike you
trying to learn how to program you're
trying to learn a new language you're
going to suck at the beginning you're
going to make a ton of mistakes at the
beginning and through practice and
dedication and hard work you'll get
better so Tommy I'm feeling the pain I'm
trying to send some love and my best
advice for you is don't worry about the
failure and just start doing every day
put out a new story get better practice
continued learning and eventually you're
close the gap your abilities will match
your taste and you'll be a much more
happy more successful fulfilled
entrepreneur believe thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know what
you think about this concept about that
gap between your skills and your taste
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to see what you think
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon